ああああああ
道
me
あっはっはー
ポング中は始めましたらはじめチェーンバッグあっソルトを持つよねはい合わせており
ますね
まあ腫瘍が使えませんバッテリーが入りません50回連続射撃可能
ほっパックピナーカてではあなたはよく分かりませんあっっっとミニショットガンって
こちら何かと言いますと早打ちプロスワーキャーね
そういうことがは確かに入って有罪ですけどもうそんなぶち殺すことはないと思っ
ちゃうんですよね十全会も興味で買っちまったはいを殺すよのちょっと噛んでる何か魂
がで仕様らしいんですよどうなんだねでも言いたいかどうかよくわかんないですけど
今日は何かすごいが10本やでもゴリとしっかりしてるからこれで本当に入る頃制度
ノーライネスでミット誰でも使えますって書いてありますどこが白い
いるみたいです本当に首位練度を待って来はこれまた弱いと月じゃないからそれを
リロードリロードしちゃったというといつもってボタンで浮かんだよこんなコート
セーフティ
あっ
強だないですね
うわこれマップめっちゃか強いじゃんかさー bb 弾11買わないといけないじゃ嫌
韓ってそれがお塩ですムって結構画期的だと思うんですよね身近にあるものが武器に
なるてすごい
あと果たしつの威力があるかどうかでございます本当にお城でいることがたいときで
調子を入りました
これでリロードして戻してロックを解除して打てる
ああああああああ
今でたは風に吹か the 確認できなかったんですよ
上に出てなくねでているのかなことに全然わかんないよえてます
っと
れている
出てる出てる出てる
出てるなぁ
[音楽]
自分で言ってみようかな
会え店や黙ってなっており機がもうちょっとさに気が多いから汚したくない
やっぱりさあ自分で試さなきゃ自分で試さなきゃダメで山地板設置ますうちます
[音楽]
3通ふあ
うんこいこい声はこれじゃあ zu ちょっとっ
今日でチャンネル終わるかも保存だよああああ
俺うってくれよポンポンってパテてまってまってお客ウケポリは顧客を張ってまで待っ
て待って待って待って待って
うーん学校非エロ
それじゃ
こりゃ林にますわなうわぁこれなるほどね
あのちょうどいい具合に宅配が死ぬいたソロ c 1 b
痛いけどなるほどって感じですただ顔に行っちゃダメだなこれなんかホビー怠惰な
わかるこの痛み
pga
[拍手]
程よく痛いですよこれは
うん大丈夫あのちょうどいい高さでちょっと弟言ってみますって言いたいじゃなくない
から今の半々のウザー
だけない痛くないよ餌が伊豆の旅
っていう
は行って
あっはいそうそうなその配慮して抜いたからな
various はいと言うけど今から実際にこのお塩を使ったショットガン年たに
眠るこう how ちょっと叩き起こしやろうと思いますあいつはな競演家に来ると
言わなかったに無断で止まったんでそれなりだねやっぱ
コストが払われるわけですよねもうだ等価交換がない発ぶち込んでやるじゃん
[音楽]
ああああああ
ん
ben tre
ああああああ
[音楽]
ていません
goo
[音楽]
me
car
teal
me
ana あああっ
うんうんあれこれ言いたいのかな本当にネタ像ですからそれだけっ
r ん